all right let's go next to our caller
from the 7 to 0 area code 72 0 go ahead
hey David my question for you is with
net neutrality going away in a couple
months what do you think will be the
immediate effect well we're already
seeing that the big cable providers are
starting to work on all of their tiered
plans we're going listen the exact stuff
all the cable providers said they would
never ever do and they have no interest
in doing whatsoever while it's not
allowed all that stuff is the first
thing that we're going to see so that I
mean and we're already seeing AT&T and
some other big cable providers remove
elements from their promises as to what
they will and won't do and that we're
gonna see that right away there's not
gonna be any surprise whatsoever ok so
you think it'll be tiered pricing like
right out of the gate just June 1st or
whatever whatever the date is it will
probably all be done in a slightly more
nuanced way but we're going to very
quickly see the the exact mechanisms
that the prior regulations prevented
from being put in place you will start
to see those go in place now they might
be hidden under clever names or reworded
or structured so they don't appear to be
those things but they're going to be
those things okay all right well thanks
for your insight all right very good
thank you appreciate the call